so city projects been releasing bits of
DLC for The Witcher 3 since its release
we've got some armor some beard diagrams
a new look for yen some crossbows while
these are all cool and certainly by
today's standards really generous I've
been more looking forward to see them
play to their strengths and add more
stories and side quests well there's
already been an additional contract in
the Skellig Islands and now for the week
of June 8 they're gonna be releasing a
free DLC side quest I've been lucky
enough to give it a go a bit early it
fits right in with the rest of the game
with some dark humor and some even
darker intrigue you'll find the quest in
a little village called lurch located
directly east of linden Vale and north
of down warn you'll be up against in
level 5 to 6 necker's and bandits in
your attempt to find out what happened
to this little village so there isn't
really a barrier to entry here I don't
want to spoil anything so I'll just
leave it at this if you find yourself
wandering around no man's land sometime
this week after about the 9th of the
10th take a pit stop and lurch
you